Jean-Luc Picard is back for a new adventure
in Star Trek: Picard, once again boldly going
where no one has gone before.
The CBS All Access show is filled with callbacks
to Star Trek past, including some that might
elude even the most dedicated of fans.
After opening with a flashback to Picard's
resignation from Starfleet 14 years earlier,
the third episode of Picard, titled "The End
is the Beginning," finds the erstwhile Admiral
paying a visit to his former first officer,
Raffi, who was fired from Starfleet after
Picard resigned.
Raffi is now living in a self-described "hovel"
in the Vasquez Rocks, where it seems she passes
her time getting high and trying to forget
the years she spent working alongside Picard.
However, for long-time Star Trek fans, the
Vasquez Rocks are more than just a cool location
for Raffi to park her 24th century trailer.
The Vasquez Rocks Natural Area Park, located
in the Sierra Pelona Mountains in northern
California, has been a frequent shooting location
for past Star Trek productions, including
episodes of the original series, The Next
Generation, Voyager, and Enterprise, along
with scenes in the films Star Trek IV: The
Voyage Home, J.J. Abrams' 2009 Star Trek,
and its 2013 sequel, Star Trek Into Darkness.
As a matter of fact, the Vasquez Rocks have
been featured so prominently within Star Trek
lore that the location has even been nicknamed
"Kirk's Rock."
When Picard meets his new pilot-for-hire,
Cristóbal "Chris" Rios, it's under less than
ideal circumstances, as Rios is in the process
of having a piece of titanium shrapnel removed
from his shoulder.
In order for the Emergency Medical Hologram
to access the injury, Rios is shirtless, giving
us a clear view at the prominent mermaid tattoo
on his upper left arm.
Rios' ship is named the La Sirena, which translates
from Spanish as "The Mermaid."
It makes sense that Rios would have such a
strong personal connection to his ship that
he'd want to permanently mark it on his body,
but his choice to name his ship "The Mermaid"
could also be a hint that Rios and Picard
may have more in common than it might appear.
"Do I detect a certain bitterness toward Starfleet?"
Mermaids and mermaid tattoos have long been
associated with a romanticized image of sailors
heading out on perilous voyages, which is
how Picard often seemed to view his role as
the commander of a Federation starship.
This was made plain by the opening of Star
Trek: Generations, in which Picard and the
crew of the Enterprise stepped into their
equivalent roles as officers on a 19th century
naval ship.
"Just imagine what it was like.
No engines, no computers — just the wind
and the sea and the stars to guide you."
Rios' embracing of such a classic maritime
symbol may indicate that despite their apparent
differences, Rios and Picard may in fact be
kindred spirits.
After they meet, Picard notices that Rios
is in the middle of reading a hardcover version
of The Tragic Sense of Life by Miguel de Unamuno.
Written in 1912, it's a philosophical essay
following the author's struggle to reconcile
man's pursuit of wisdom, knowledge, and reason
with his belief that those pursuits and consciousness
in general actually work in opposition to
leading a happy life.
The particular passage that Rios is reading
later on in the episode, on page 140 of the
book, deals with the link between consciousness
and suffering, in which Unamuno muses,
"How do we know that we exist if we do not
suffer, little or much?
How can we turn upon ourselves, acquire reflective
consciousness, save by suffering?"
While Picard hasn't been explicitly shown
to be a fan of this author, it's well established
that he's a learned, philosophical man.
Rios' interest in philosophy is yet another
clue that the pilot may have more in common
with the Admiral than meets the eye.
But the passage Rios was reading also seems
to point somewhat ominously to the themes
of sentience and personhood that so strongly
define Picard.
Unamuno argues that suffering is essential
to consciousness, and that without it, we
have no way of knowing that we are truly alive
a philosophy that we may see revisited as
we learn more about Dahj and Soji's origins,
and the circumstances leading up to the synthetic
uprising.
Despite Raffi's insistence that she wants
no part of Picard's new mission, he sends
her all of the information he has on Bruce
Maddox's research anyway, and she can't help
digging into it.
As Raffi sifts through the files from the
Daystrom Institute, there's a brief shot of
her screen, on which the words "Crypto Algorithm
Identification: Gorn Egg" can be read.
The Gorn are a reptilian alien species first
introduced on the classic Trek episode, "Arena,"
in which Captain Kirk is transported to the
surface of a rocky planet filmed at the Vasquez
Rocks by aliens called the Metrons, and told
he must battle the captain of an opposing
Gorn ship to the death.
Only the winner's ship and crew will survive.
Kirk and the Gorn captain both manage to injure
one another, but Kirk ultimately decides to
show mercy and spare the Gorn's life, which
in turn leads to both crews being spared by
the Metrons.
"No I won't kill him.
Do you hear?
You'll have to get your entertainment someplace
else."
At the end of "Arena," the Metrons tell Kirk
that while humans are a savage race, there
is hope for them due to their capacity to
show mercy to their enemies.
Conversely, the beginning of Picard's third
episode finds Picard and Raffi lamenting that
the Federation is refusing to show mercy to
the Romulans, capitulating instead to "intolerance
and fear."
Had Kirk given into those same tendencies
in "Arena," it would've led to a far different
and more disastrous outcome.
Despite Rios' many personal similarities to
Picard, the pilot is initially reluctant to
agree to help the former Starfleet Admiral
when they first meet.
Later, when Rios is alone in his quarters,
the Emergency Medical Hologram appears and
attempts to talk Rios into helping Picard,
despite his reservations.
"So, are we excited?
Intimidated?
Maybe a teensy bit starstruck?"
As the EMH runs down his laundry list of Picard's
accomplishments, he mentions that Picard was
"chief contact with the Q continuum," which
is a reference to both the pilot episode and
series finale of Star Trek: The Next Generation,
as well as a number of notable episodes during
the series run.
Picard's encounters with Q also led to the
first introduction of, and subsequent attacks
by the Borg.
He also mentions that Picard was "Arbiter
of Succession for the Klingon Empire," which
was already nodded to in Picard's premiere
episode, and that he was "captain of the Enterprises
D and E," a reference that needs no explanation.
The EMH wraps up his exultations of Picard
by name-dropping that he "worked alongside
the great Spock," calling back to the Next
Generation episode "Unification," and could
also be a nod to Spock's role in attempting
to prevent the Romulan supernova, as explained
in 2009's Star Trek.
While most of Picard's storyline takes place
on Earth, all of Dahj's twin sister Soji's
scenes have been set aboard a Romulan reclamation
station on a repurposed Borg cube, on which
she encounters an ex-Borg drone named Hugh.
Hugh first appeared in the Next Generation
episode "I Borg", which saw the Enterprise
crew encounter a young Borg drone who had
been abandoned by the Collective.
Although Picard initially sees the Borg as
nothing more than a way to help him bring
down the Collective, he ultimately is forced
to recognize his sentience and personhood
when the drone begins exhibiting signs of
individuality and gives himself the name "Hugh."
"I will not assist you."
"'I?'"
Hugh pops up again in the two-part TNG episode
"Descent," where it is revealed that after
rejoining the Collective, his sense of individuality
spread to his entire cube, and they were cut
off from the Collective.
In "Descent," Hugh proved himself a loyal
ally of Picard and the Enterprise, rescuing
several members of the crew and resisting
Data's megalomaniacal brother, Lore.
"You're kind of a know-it-all, aren't you."
It's hard to predict what's in store for Hugh
on Picard, but if Hugh's past history with
the Admiral are any indication, he may prove
to be an important albeit unexpected ally
for Picard and his rogue crew.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.